thank you to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS Digital Studios have you
ever thought about investing in the
stock market maybe you have a cousin or
a co-worker who's always talking about
how their portfolio is doing and you
think maybe I should be doing that too
but then you do a little research and it
sounds like this Dow's worst week
there's a risk out there for textile
volatility Oh yikes you know it reminds
me of the time I walked up to a craps
table in Vegas the rules were so
complicated and confusing how could I
justify flogging down my hard-earned
money on a game of chance I barely
understood a lot of people feel the same
way half of Americans have zero dollars
invested in stocks many of them don't
have the spare money to invest but some
might think it's just for risk-taking
high rollers but is the stock market
just a big casino or is it something
that you should be making a part of your
financial plans
[Music]
what exactly is a stock the concept was
invented in the 17th century by the
Dutch East India Trading Company which
wanted to allow multiple investors to
underwrite their expeditions so they
sold shares or percentages of the
company worked out well for Dutch East
India making them the biggest company in
the history of the known universe with a
value greater in today's dollars than
Apple Google and Facebook combined today
you can buy stock in companies of all
sizes betting that the company will do
well and the value of your shares will
increase smaller newer firms are more
risky because while there's a chance
they could be the next uber there's a
much bigger chance they could go bust
larger established companies aren't
quite as exciting but they're a lot more
stable I mean who doesn't think
coca-cola will still be selling soda
tomorrow it sounds a lot like the odds
at a horse race but on the favorite to
win a little bit of money or go for the
big bucks by risking it all on a
longshot so why not just get the
brokerage fees and just go to the
racetrack when you look at the stock
market up close it can sure seem like a
gamble but you might be missing the
forest for the trees
for instance track one company's share
price for one year and it looks like a
wild ride who'd want to put their
savings on that rollercoaster but let's
take a few steps back instead of just
one company let's look at a bunch of
companies and instead of one year let's
look at 90 the S&P 500 index is a
measurement of how 500 of the biggest
companies have performed over time and
since 1928 it has grown by an average of
10 percent per year
sure there is still ups and downs but
what looked completely unpredictable up
close from a wider perspective tells a
different story so how do you get your
portfolio the collection of stocks you
own to mirror that steady increase the
two main tactics are diversification and
long term investing stock
diversification means owning stocks from
a lot of different companies which
protects you from the volatility of any
specific sector and long term investing
owning stocks for at least 10 years
protects you from the volatility of any
one bad day even a really bad day when
the market crashed into
thousand eight many people rushed to
sell out their stocks and just ate the
losses but those who could stay in
eventually made that money back plus
some behavioral economist Richard Taylor
actually recommends very rarely checking
in on your portfolio people who
regularly track the prices of their
shares tend to get spooked and sell them
when they temporarily dip which is
basically guaranteeing that they sell
them for less than they bought them the
number one no-no of playing the stock
market these strategies reveal how
different from a casino the stock market
actually is casinos in Las Vegas have
payout percentages that average in the
mid-90s meaning they pay back in
winnings around 95 percent of the money
that is gambled so if you played Las
Vegas like a stock broker diversifying
your portfolio by playing a bunch of
different games and long term investing
by keeping your money on the table
whether you win or lose each day you can
be fairly certain you've steadily lose
5% of your savings it doesn't take an
economist to tell you that losing money
and making money are two very different
things
of course there is still some risk
involved even a diversified portfolio
can take a dive and when life deals you
a bad card you might need that money now
not 5 or 10 years down the road when the
market goes back up
so is it smarter to just keep your money
in a savings account
well not playing the stock market
carries its own risks as employer funded
pensions become less and less common
Americans are increasingly on their own
when it comes to saving for retirement
and as companies continue to grow and
everything gets more expensive if your
savings are not somehow tied to the
overall growth of the economy you can
get left behind so where do you start
most people buy and sell individual
stocks through a company is called
brokerage firms it's actually pretty
easy to set up an account and they offer
guidance on how to invest your money for
a commission of course you can always
pick stocks yourself but if you're new
to it that can be as risky as a flop
machine another more common way to own
stocks is through mutual funds you might
already own some in the form of a 401k
these are preassembled bundles of stocks
and other investment
that are designed in advance to be
diversified which spreads out the risk
and makes them less of a hassle well be
covering mutual funds in more depth in a
future episode like any big investment
the smartest first step is to seek the
help of an investment advisor who is a
sworn fiduciary who can help you make a
plan that fits your unique situation
remember even if you keep your savings
in cash under your mattress you are
still part of the larger economy which
means in some sense you're already
invested in the game so you may as well
be playing with some strategy and that's
our two cents thank you to curiosity
stream for supporting PBS Digital
Studios curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers documentaries and nonfiction
titles from a variety of filmmakers
including curiosity stream originals for
example you can watch 1929 to hear more
about the ups and downs of the stock
market you can learn more at curiosity
stream comm / 2 cents and use the code
two cents during the signup process
do you have more stock market questions
post them in the comments and we'll try
to answer them and if you'd like to
share your own experiences with
investing in stocks we'd love to hear
them
[Music]